Why don't we go next to, um.
Oh, this is interesting.
Let's go to Maria from Colombia, but calling
from Germany.
Do I have that right, Maria?
Yes, you're right.
I love it, what now you I don't know if you've
heard this caller, Pedro, from Colombia, who
clearly is is not from Colombia, what part
of Colombia are you actually from?
And from Bogota?
OK, that's that's a that's a clear answer.
And so I believe you.
OK, good.
That's an easy one, but, yeah, definitely
doesn't have a Colombian accent.
No, not at all.
OK, good.
Oh, by the way, I am watching a you might
find this interesting, Maria.
I have started watching a Netflix series called
Perret either which takes place mostly in
Colombia, and it's quite good.
I have not heard of it, but I'm going to watch
it, please.
Definitely.
But enough about me.
What's on your mind today?
On my mind?
Well, I have family issues trying to communicate
with them.
And I remember that once you said that, for
example, to talk about controversial issues
like abortion, it's good to have like a common
ground, like what everyone should agree on.
And for example, everyone should agree on
having less abortions, even if you're pro-choice
or if you're pro-life.
And that has helped me a lot.
And I was wondering whether you have another
topic in mind that it's controversial, but
that we can find a common ground maybe.
Yeah, I don't know.
I mean, there's so many it would be better
if you had a topic that you're looking to
discuss and we could think about the best
way to do it.
Is there a particular topic that is a problem
right now?
Well, regarding covid, I think right now,
my family right now, especially my grandfather,
he's suffering now from covid and his saturation
levels are very low and it feels like I'm
hopeless.
I don't know.
I would I wish I could communicate with them
a lot better, but I just.
Yeah, it's complicated.
But is it that you're so your family, they're
not taking the virus seriously or they believe
it's a hoax or what?
What's the disagreement?
They believe at the beginning they thought
it was a hoax.
Now, one of my uncles, he got infected and
he was on a ventilator for eighty six days.
He survived.
Yes, but still, it seemed like well, actually,
I guess it everything starts with a lack of
trust, the health care workers.
I think that's the main issue.
And you know what's interesting about that?
Here's the opportunity, right?
Here's the opportunity.
If if your family doesn't trust the health
care workers, the best way to avoid having
to interact with them is not to get the virus.
So where I where I might approach this is
hey, you know what?
Nobody wants to have to deal with health care
workers if you don't have to.
So that should be extra incentive to stay
healthy so we don't end up needing health
care workers to do anything for us.
I would probably think of that as the entry
point.
Oh, yeah, I agree, I agree.
Sounds that's a very reasonable.
But now to understand the family that you're
referring to there in Germany or there in
Colombia or there somewhere else?
Oh, well, my grandfather and my aunts there
in Southern California, so, OK, so it's all
over the place.
All right.
Well, listen, that sounds tough, but that's
that's my thought, Maria.
Yeah, thanks.
Thanks, everyone, all sure.
I appreciate your opinion.
Thank you so much.
Oh, is there someone else there now?
Yes, my boyfriend.
Is he Colombian?
Yes.
Oh, he is.
Oh, all right, well, listen, you are the real
Colombian callers and you are replacing Pedro
from Colombia, so congratulations.
Thank thing.
All right.
Take care.
OK, let's take a very quick break.
But if you're holding, don't hang up.
I mean, hang up if you want to, but I do have
an opportunity to speak with me if you keep
holding, because we'll go right back to the
phones momentarily.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.